I want to start today since we're
dealing with China probably more than
anything although not exclusively China
by recommending a novel and it's just
just been published by amitav Ghosh who
is anthropologist who has taught here in
the Columbia from time to time and it's
entitled river of smoke it is the sequel
to a novel called the sea of poppies sea
of poppies is primarily seafaring in the
the seafaring culture of the Indian
Ocean
river of smoke is primarily about and
trade and Tom in the era of the leading
up to the first wheel it is like notable
in his use of the contemporary slang and
you know
obsolete words of various languages for
that particular period you run into and
many many senses with three words that
you have never seen before you will
never see again sort of you know out of
Gudda Gudda young and and I'll bash yeah
stop but you figure it out in content
from time to time you'll run across a
word one of these totally strange work
and they'll recognize
I mean I'll run various languages but
old gin such and such or Oh to say nasty
thing it was you don't really feel like
looking yep then we'll see you ah sorry
in the river so the real America is
because it deals with what for people
who are participating in in notion trade
in the early nineteen seven
in southern China culture of that
particular it can be compared with the
novel type an by James Clavell
very very successful novel was made and
we I believe
yeah and that also was the culture of
Canton but when you look at claw Bell's
novel you discover that almost all the
principal characters are Americans or
Europeans whereas you look at Ghosh's
novel and you'll find almost none of the
characters or principal characters are
Americans or Europeans they are parsy's
and Indian Chinese Armenians and so
forth and the comparison is interesting
because one of the one of the truths of
history these days is that an awful lot
of people get their history from
historical novels then there's question
of what is it that allows you to get a
historical novel published and this is
always a kind of a back and forth
between a publisher and an author what I
discovered what I published my first
novel is that
you call one alley and call another one
o yousufzai the reader say one of them
is always a struggle right that is
always described as having a tiny
pointed beard
well foreign for foreign names just for
together for American ears and so the
fact the matter is that that historical
fiction set outside of the European
context written by Americans at least
and published in America usually will
have a Western character who is the
protagonist and who's the hook for the
for the narrative so that you follow oh
here's a story about oh the era of
seljuq invasion of the Middle East and
just happens that there is a an English
crusade has abandoned the fight and the
Holy Land and has gone off to around so
let's follow him because nobody can
remember who you know you know Muhammad
good Fulani is or whatever it is so one
of the one of the things about gosh I he
has such a reputation and such a strong
research base for his novels that the
publishers you know publish these books
that I devoted to the overseas career so
strange p.m. Wanderers and it gives a
completely different texture of things
it doesn't mean he doesn't describe the
Europeans but he describes them mostly
from as seen by an Armenian from Cairo
or a Parsi from from Gujarat rather than
in and of themselves and as such he's
able to describe them always would be
harder to do for example Canton which
was the one
place that Europeans could trade in
early 19th century China you know in
Kowloon where the European colony was it
was for prohibited for any Western woman
to set foot the place so all the
European and particularly British
businessman who have factories or
warehouses of what they called exam in
Kowloon and are doing business and stay
for years they're all gay and it's you
know not every single one of them but as
portrayed by gauche they're all no
they're happy they get to live there and
they always have a friend who is their
companion of many years and they hold
dances and know you have principal
characters of Parsi businessman who's
saying to someone oh it's a walls let us
go and dance and but if you reek level
you get principal characters are two
American sailors who are in business
competition of a very strength just one
another it's it's very very the fact
that it's set in in China so so I
recommend this it has been a
characteristic of social history of the
last few decades that the lives of
ordinary people if they are narrated
well are considered to innate for
history in an unusually vivid fashion so
a book like the return of Martin guerre
by dad Elysium and Davis from Princeton
is a classic because it's telling the
story of a medieval period when a man
comes
from the wars to pick up where he left
off when he went to war but it's not
clear whether he's the same man and the
debate is was Martin guerre the real
Martin guerre or was he an imposter who
would come back he made into a movie set
in the American Civil War context in
this country Richard Gere I think
started it or the cheese in the worms by
Carlo Ginsburg a number of books like
this one of the best of ones of them is
a book called Empire made to be a story
of a man an Englishman a true story in
this case who volunteered very young for
World War one in Britain at the end of
the war he did not want to go back to
becoming her clerk or an apprentice so
he signed up to become a policeman in
Shanghai and spent the rest of his life
in Shanghai and the story of an order of
an English policeman in Shanghai over 40
years is really absolutely gripping and
he becomes you know completely fluent in
Chinese and hates the Chinese and
eventually is thrown out of the police
force for brutality toward the Chinese
and then he becomes a enforcer for
various European companies who are
trying to keep Chinese labor in line and
eventually the Japanese take over the
factory and shoot him and so his family
said Oh we'd like him to be considered
the first British casualty of world war
two and then ends up being a debate over
that but these stories of ordinary
people make a very whether they are
fictionalized us in the case of ghosts
or whether they are memoirs or whether
carefully crafted you know bits of
historical research presented as as
factual they make a very useful antidote
to the tendency in in general history
courses such as this one to deal with
things at a general level because of the
general level
you tend to move up the social and
political scale and talk about people
who are thought to have made had an
impact rather than people upon whom an
impact was had by the by the events and
there's a fairly large library of books
of this kind as I say some fictional
some non fictional and I can they're
more common for European history where
you don't have the the issue of the
alienists of the characters but this one
by gauche is is unusually good
particularly because it deals with what
the trade and the Indian Ocean was like
this is one of the hardest things I
think to to get some sort of sense of
because we we talk a great deal about
the Indian Ocean trade and about the
flows of Commerce from China to India to
Europe and Africa and back and it tends
to who leave the human dimension behind
so listen I strongly recommend of this
book now because the Europeans were cut
off from the interior of China by this
very strict ruling that businessmen
could not trade outside of captain and
then this ultimately leads to the first
and the second opium wars when the the
British are willing to go to war to
protect their their drug business
basically sort of
you know the wire set in 19th century
China with the big drug dealers you know
being the big de British because of that
and because of some declarations made by
high-ranking Chinese that we do not need
your European imports you know
you don't need your budgets we were
entirely independent and live with
Ireland manufacturers because of that
there there's an image that china
doesn't change very much and that it
isn't it buys products through Canton
European products and cells through Kent
um but you don't have much change
interior to China views of that are are
in the process of changing new books
that have come out in recent years have
attempted to show that there's a lot of
penetration of European goods into
Indochina and of processes for making
them and so forth but they tend not to
be perceived very well because they're
at a very very popular level in other
words this is not steel mills and you
know Steamship Lines so much as o
household goods and you know
cloth of a fairly simple variety you
know manchester woollen cloth did get
into China but it wasn't at a high end
and the so the idea that China was kind
of a isolated land or that didn't have
much much effect on it from the outside
his seems less and less tenable you also
have clothing changes that begin to come
in you know some of them of Western
Western inspiration but the one I want
to talk about comes in toward the end of
the period of this chapter that is say
in the seemingly in the late 1860's and
ends up having a huge impact not just in
China but in many of the many Asian and
Indian Ocean Rim countries and this is
the rickshaw
though we spend so much time talking
about railroads changing the
transportation economy or automobiles
for bicycles all these things of the
Europeans come up with that changed the
way in which people communicate the way
in which people move and so forth and in
some respects the rickshaw is as
important as any of them because it's
coming into a into societies that
previously had not for passenger use
used wheeled vehicles very much the
rickshaw is of uncertain origin it is
usually ascribed to an American
missionary in Japan named Jonathan Goble
who supposedly had a a wife who was an
invalid could not get around so he
invented the rickshaw and within a
couple of years or thousands of
rickshaws you think well there's one
busy missionary or else there is a
legend and it seems particularly since
different sources give the missionaries
name with different spellings like one
of them is not doable but Scobie and so
it's not just uh-oh
there's something really wrong with this
story but it probably is is right in the
sense that if carries on the notion that
Westerners invent things Japanese
historians sort of concur on the
identification of a Japanese inventor
for the rickshaw and
and they can demonstrate that he
actually received he and two others
received licenses to produce and sell
rickshaws where there's no evidence that
Reverend goby
Goble Scobie whoever he was went into
the manufacturing of rickshaws okay what
is a rickshaw a rickshaw is a is a
two-wheeled vehicle very lightweight
made primarily out of bamboo for its
super structure it has shafts they go
you know thin bamboo poles that go up on
either side and you stand between the
poles and you pull it in the French it
was called a pousse pousse so if you
look it up in the French Wikipedia
you'll get look it up under pousse
pousse not on your rickshaw the the
passenger you might have two passengers
would sit in in a certain amount of
comfort and be pulled along this tended
to have fairly large diameter wheels
with with a large number of spokes but
nowhere it'll probably gave a pretty
smooth ride as long as you were on a
fairly smooth pavement 1868 is given and
yet there are illustrations that go back
a hundred twenty years earlier from here
and they're showing vehicles that are
obviously in the same category so what
appears to be the case is that the idea
of having essentially a very very light
cart of the sort you might have pulled
by a pony or a horse but having it
pulled by the human the idea seems to
occur it again and again but it doesn't
become an industry until this time
the alternatives that you have that's
for example goats will talk about people
riding around in in Canton in either a
sedan chair or a pousse pousse I'm not
sure whether his pousse pousse is exact
the same as the fresh pousse pousse he
spells it differently but the the sedan
chair was two poles that had a little
house built on it and the passenger sat
inside and then these are carried on the
shoulders of men and your rank was often
indicated by how heavy your sedan chair
was so someone could have one carried by
8 men you know four in front for me back
I have illustrations that go up to what
the level of 30 men carrying a sedan
chair that's basically quite like a
small house now 15 in front and 15 and I
was 32 16 in front 60 in the back I
think was a picture we saw so the sedan
chair was the standard way of traveling
the meiji emperor of japan who is the
seen as the emperor who presides over
first period of modernization in japan
in the second half of the 19th century
the meiji emperor of japan who ruled for
a long time never went anywhere except
in a sedan chair so if he wanted to
observe military sizes that were 200
miles away from his from his palace
he would get in a sedan chair and he
would be carried 200 miles through the
forest and up and down the mountains and
so forth and that he never travelled in
the carriage the carriage was something
introduced by Europeans carriages and
pet dog play in Japan were always show
up in illustrations of the first year
coming along but catch on very well to
have a carriage menu had to have horses
horses required a certain amount of up a
certain amount of knowledge how do you
hire a stableboy who has never seen a
horse before and expect your horse to be
taken care of plus I mean think of this
as a really big advantage of being
pulled around by people inside of my
horses there's no manure on the street
you know New York City London but their
streets for just by 1900 they were just
ankle-deep and manure all the time
because of all me as Chinese or Japanese
or Indian streets wow we're we're
cleaner we never talked about things
like that about the fundamental
filthiness of the modern world that that
the Industrial Revolution fostered in
Europe but the rickshaw was clean it was
comfortable it was fast by comparison to
a sedan chair partly because of such a
light structure that a rickshaw wallah
can run getting your 8 sedan chair
holders with on the shoulder to run at
the same time were you bouncing on them
that's not so good so you tend to walk
with a stand chair in England sedan
chairs were used for prostitutes because
I could be
you could be delivered to your to your
mansion without anyone seeing who they
were but they were the standard upper
class transportation in the East because
the the rickshaw was simply you know one
man one vehicle it hit a much more
popular stratum of society than the
sedan chair sedan chair at the very
minimum you had to have two bearers you
know one in front and one and you
probably needed more than two so the
cost of going from place to place on in
any way other than walking suddenly goes
down and so you see that the rickshaws
that come into China in the at the end
of the 1860s all imported from Japan I
mean we think that it's what's important
is what do the Europeans export to China
but here you have a transformative
technology in which initially the
manufacturing is being done in Japan and
we quickly become you look in 2020 500
that 20,000 and you know 80,000 I mean
they become extremely common they show
up in China they show up in Japan and
then they're imported into India then
they're imported in yellow only in the
colonies in India ported into French
Matic then they show up in South Africa
so the entire literal of the Indian
Ocean and going up into the Sea of Japan
South China Sea
is undergoing a transition pollution was
related to a new industry in a new
industry in an area of invention and
industrial growth that the Europeans
pride themselves on and yet the
Europeans had nothing to do with it
except of course that the people who
were importing these things into place
like India Madagascar probably were as
much French merchants and English
merchants as they were local merchants
so is there anything further to this
well yeah in a sense
we get to the point where it's outside
the time frame here something to the
early 20th century but it's estimated
that in a big city like Calcutta 20% of
the population is made up of rickshaw
pullers the number you have you know one
person per rich all the number of people
who get engaged in this at the low end
of employment is simply enormous and
then and then you think oh well what
would be the equivalent in Europe is
this the equivalent say you have a
factory worker someone who comes in from
the countryside has no particular skills
that's hired in a factory to you know to
work 16 hours a day at a relatively low
skill level in order to make enough
money to survive then the equivalent in
India would appear to be the villager
who comes into the city has no
particular skills but this is the job
that's available for someone with no
skills and at the low end of the of the
income scale and this is how you make
enough money money to survive if you go
to Calcutta today it's about the only
place left where you still will you'll
still have
man drawn rickshaws when you talk to
Americans who go to Calcutta
particularly those who go and intending
to stay for a while as opposed to
tourists you often get this sense of
guilt
people say well I'll go in a motor
rickshaw which is where you put a little
putt-putt motor in front of the rickshaw
when I don't like to ride in a rickshaw
because that's exploiting human labor
you think you know what do you think
you're doing when you buy a Big Mac or
some other low-end they'll no hope no
future employment thing in the United
States is that not but it's the idea the
person is actually actually running and
pulling you and Americans just often
feel really really bad about that
and yet this was a major part of the the
social transformation
how do cities grow if as they do
throughout the 19th 20th centuries if
they do not have low-end
employment so even though this you can't
find at least I've been able to find a
history of the rickshaw its ubiquity and
the the role it plays in the employment
structure of different countries and the
way in which it transforms human human
transport for poor people to have cheap
wheels as opposed to walking it makes a
big difference so then you want to
applied in the rickshaw go farther first
we have a handful of peda cabs in New
York now which is a variation on the
rickshaw using a bicycle Drive instead
of running but
and I know people who wouldn't get in a
pedicab so now I don't want to exploit
that person's labor as if there's
something wrong with humans actually
working I don't know it's uh seems to be
a guilt thing I don't think anyone in
the 19th century ever had three seconds
of guilt about exploiting human labor
nevertheless
I along with the one I was talking about
last week of the the lithographed book
where where you have a technology that
has a transformative capacity and great
economic and social impact but has
minimal intersection with what's
happening in Europe except that it's
happening at the same time and that of
course goes back to this question of if
new things are coming in doesn't a a
climate of receptivity for new things
you know if there's something new how do
you get people to to adopt it I mean if
everyone saw a rickshaw and said no I
just wouldn't feel comfortable in that
then it's not going to succeed take the
Segway you know how many have seen a
Segway on the streets of New York I
think I've seen to change and
transportation that it was Valley who
does when it first came out because
there does seem to be something to do
with the the mood of the times in terms
of a of the receptivity to to change and
I'm just arguing that even though we we
celebrate the receptivity to change of
Europe in the 19th century that
receptivity to change seems to have
or not spread but to have existed in
many other parts of the world as well at
the same time leading to the question of
what was the 19th century all about why
was it a period of so much change and
trying to get away from the notion that
that change was uniquely associated with
with European you know brilliance and
innovation and it was some appears to
have been much much broader in its
impact
all right end of that topic but I think
it will work around back to it the way I
do sometimes because I want to talk
about a different topic this is
something for better for one of a better
turn I'll call charisma disparity this
is a way of income disparities that some
people are having more experience of
charismatic excitement than others this
is something that we have today people
who take Jesus Christ as their personal
Savior take Jesus Christ as their
personal Savior
and they actually do say you know what
would Jesus do and it's exciting for
them and it's satisfying for them and it
really works and those in our population
I don't want to say those of us I don't
want to tip off where I might be on this
but who don't do that think you know WTF
I mean it's you know does this really
does really does this really is this
really happening in America today that
yeah I mean this is bizarre so now we
have a polity that is severely divided
on the issue of whether this is you know
something really really stupid and
primitive or whether this really is the
way the way to live
and I don't want to take a vote but my
guess is that over the last 10 or 12
years the number of people at Columbia
who are on Jesus aside has steadily
crept up and the number of people who
are really really scared probably has
crept up as well because you're getting
this this cleavage this disparity people
who search for and the chief require
charisma and those who who just don't
see the point
all right now what I want says that to
some degree century is marked by a
profound disparity in desire for of
charisma we have a chapter on the
Industrial Revolution but we don't talk
much about religion and yet if you if
you look at the 19th century globally
instead of specifically at those things
that either begin in Europe or radiate
out from Europe or our functions of
European Imperial or military or
economic domination then then you see
you know there's an awful lot of
religious so in the 19th century
for differently there's an awful lot of
charismatic dynamism the 19th century
now the reason I put it in the latter
way is because nationalism is
conceivable as a form of charisma that
people who were excited by a national
project to create Italy or Germany or
France or Bulgaria or something the
excitement that people got from from
intense national feelings or intense
patriotic feelings I would argue is in
the same ballpark as the excitement
people got from very powerful religious
feelings and that the simultaneity
of the rise of nationalism first in
Europe and then more broadly and the
incidence of these very powerful
charismatic movements is probably not
simply a matter of coincidence I think
if you if you go century by century
nineteenth century does stand out for
intensity of feeling compared with say
the coal
pick a century 15th century China turns
out to be one of the places where this
is this is particularly strongly in
evidence from the beginning of the
century to the end of the century
beginning of the century from 1818 14
you had a something known as the eight
trigrams rebellion the eight trigrams
rebellion is given its name from a
particular set of characters that come
out of being booked on divination in
China and they're these trigrams are
have our cusine to have a certain no a
certain power but it was primarily a
inspiration for the ideological level
and the type of Buddhism that the that
had become common in China in the post
tonk era that was a whole half tons
dozen centuries preceding 1800 you had
Pure Land Buddhism the idea that when
you die you will go to a Pure Land in
the West and that will be the paradise
that you will inhabit and that sort of
Buddhism which is in the Mahayana
category of Buddhism also had the notion
that there would be a Savior and he
would be
the Maitreya Buddha
it's the Buddhism form of messianism in
which you you anticipate the coming of a
savior and the Savior is going to to
make your your journey to paradise
possible so your Savior is someone whom
you who you are eagerly awaiting if you
are of a messianic character messianic
movements are particularly susceptible
to to charismatic preaching where you
you tell people that the Savior is
coming
that's the same and of the Savior indeed
he may be he may be in this room I don't
know but but you you you preach this and
you tell people how they must behave for
to be part of the elect who will benefit
from the coming of the Savior in the
eight trigrams rebellion which took
place in northern China him was a 18
1314 the Maitreya expected and you had
preachers for rabbit recruiters who went
from village to village telling about
the imminent coming of the Messiah and
how it would be triggered by the killing
of the Emperor and the overthrow of the
Qing the Chang regime the people who did
the the recruiting or the preaching from
village to village were martial arts
masters so there was a very strong
association between Chinese boxing or
martial arts and the this.what of the
Empire saw as a conspiracy to overthrow
overthrow the Empire as it turned out
the rebellion took place it was
suppressed in a year about a million
people killed in the process of
suppression because it was a very very
widespread rebellion of those people who
were captured who were part of the
leadership before they were executed
they were all interrogated and the
police records are preserved so the
result is that there is an excellent
book by a historian named Susan a Qin
that is the
the story of the eight trigrams
rebellion based on the on the police
police archives and it it's really
amazing because on the one hand it
describes how this conspiracy develops
over hundreds of villages with the
operatives going from village to village
telling of the eminent Camilla Maitreya
and then how you have another group that
are your core conspirators who are who
are actually going to kill the Emperor
and you get down to the description of
you know it it's kind of like you know
Mission Impossible you know here is you
know you will be stationed in a tea
house next to the gate to the palace and
you know these two over here they're
going to distract the guard and then
when then you'll go in and they actually
penetrate the Imperial Palace in Beijing
and they penetrate all the way to the
private chambers of the Emperor and the
Emperor actually avails himself of a bow
and arrow to help fight off the
assassins who have come to destroy the
Ching dynasty and and they succeed in
fighting them off the attack fails but
the rebellion goes on anyway you get
these million people killed it's a it's
not the only rebellion in China there
earlier rebellions they usually have you
know interesting names like the yellow
turbans or something like that but this
one is early 19th century and then you
go on to 1850 and you have the Taiping
rebellion of Taiping rebellion is in
southern china we write about it in this
chapter of the book
and there you have a a charismatic
individual named Hong Xiao Quan who seen
older brother of Jesus you know who knew
you know Dorie private wrote about Jesus
having a sister but I don't not quite
the same thing
so he's the older brother of Jesus and
he is leading a heading up a cult that
is Christian in in some semblance we
know of other religions that are you
know Christian and semblance but not
necessarily in every particular it
rejects the Buddhism and Confucianism
and the the local religiosity of China
at the time and the rebellion goes on
for 14 years 1850 1860 420 million
people are thought to have been to have
died in that that's not those aren't
battlefields deaths those are mostly
civilian deaths after some huge sieges
of cities that where the population was
slaughtered so as in the case of VA
trigrams rebellion the Empire prevails
the Empire Strikes Back and all of these
elet's are are killed then you go up to
the end of the century and you'll get
the Boxer Rebellion
it's a little outside our time frame but
at the end of the century the Boxer
Rebellion is strongly anti foreign and
very much focused on the on the sort of
charisma of the martial arts masters so
China seems to be strongly affected by
these charismatic charismatic movements
but it's not just not just China in Iran
at the same time you have the birth of
the behind but
we are formally talking about Iran in
this chapter but for for our purposes
here we can include it you have in 1840
a man declares himself to be the bb
which means the doorway or the gateway a
few years later the person who he
predicts to come as the next prophet the
successor to Oh Hamid appears in other
words he's the John the Baptist and then
the person who follows him is b'hala who
founds a religious sect he clearly is a
charismatic individual as is the Bab the
religious sect becomes the Baha'is and
it is
prohibited within Iran to such a degree
that you have a number of really
large-scale persecutions in Iran of the
Shiite government and the Shia clergy
trying to exterminate the the Baha'is
and those people who did not end up
following the halal ah who were called
the bobbies so the Bobby rebellions are
the efforts to put down the Baja the
bobbies and the the highs this is a
central drama for the history of Iran
the 19th century but then you look at
the highs and you say well no
interestingly they're strongly
associated with foreign trade and with
business and ultimately religious
connections outside of Iran also they
are very strongly Jewish so that many of
the converts to Baha'i ISM Jews who
convert to 2 to bhai is 'm they continue
to be important in Iran down to the
present day here you have a state that
in its constitution offers freedom of
religion to Shiites and Sunnis and Jews
and Zoroastrians and Christians but not
to the highs because of the time of the
Iranian Revolution the on the clerical
side much of the inspiration for the
revolution was a recruit essence of anti
Baha'i gsella tree you know to stamp out
to the highs partly because the highs
many of the rich Baha'i families were
very closely associated associated with
the Shah okay it's it's a charismatic
movement in Iran you have a charismatic
movement in Saudi Arabia I mentioned
before the Wahhabi ax it actually begins
in the middle of the 18th century but
after it is
stamped out they thought by Muhammad Ali
and the Egyptian Albanian army early in
the 19th century it came back there have
been three different mojave states the
first one that was destroyed while Hamid
Ali a second one in the middle of the
19th century and the third one that
comes along after World War one and is
the Saudi state of today a very very
strongly charismatic movement in other
places this sort of charisma will take
the form of of warfare against
imperialism so when the French invaded
1840 of their principal adversary is a
Sufi leader and Abdelkader known to
solitary and he's an extremely powerful
and effective leader takes a number of
years for the French to to defeat him
and send him off into highly respected
retirement and Damascus where he is so
highly respected that when you have the
anti-christian and anti-do ish riots in
1860 he becomes the protector of the
non-muslims not just in Damascus
in America to talk about other outlying
areas this is the period when you have
the rise in the Mormons appearance of
the Mormons clearly a charismatic
movement this is when William Miller
I've mentioned this before I believe he
predicts that the world will come to an
end in 1843 leading to the great
disappointment and from this comes the
seventh-day Adventist sect of
Christianity these are two well-known
movements in America but you also have
have movements that are much more
localized in the forms of utopian
communities and other forms of intense
religious you know community feeling but
probably the one that has the longest
effect is starts around 1830 and is
considered to be part of what's called
the Second Great Awakening and this is
the creation of the the seed of the
American who are the American Board of
Commissioners for foreign missions
American missionary work outside the
United State
gets its first its first strong impetus
primarily in New England among college
graduates who are intensely religious
where do they you know there are earlier
missionary movements that came back to
earlier times that focus on American
Native Americans but the American Board
of Commissioners for foreign missions
focuses on overseas missionary activity
bad activity starts by going to the Holy
Land and to the Ottoman Empire and then
those too you know
and the Philippines as they become
American missionary activity importance
of the American missionary enterprise is
increasingly being recognized by
scholars as the the most significant
content that American culture American
Way of life had on people outside the
United States in other words if you were
looking at history of French or English
or Italian or German imperialism you
would identify the perhaps the central
impact of the imperial power as being
officials that get sent from the
Metropole to administer overseas
territories and the missionaries would
would play a role but it would tend to
be a secondary role to the government
very often in fact you had adversarial
relations between colonial governments
and the missionaries who were trying to
work in their area because the officials
often thought that the missionaries were
were disruptive in the American case
because we did not have areal holdings
until after 1898 in the Philippines in
the American case the missionaries were
saw themselves found quite and quite
literally and realistically as the the
living embodiment of the American Way
they were determined to live like
Americans dressed like Americans try and
get local converts to to become
many Americans worried initially that if
they converted people to Christianity
and taught them English so they would
all immigrate to the United States
because you know you get to be an
American everybody in the world wants to
be in America they thought so they
prohibited teaching in English and said
well we'll teach in the local languages
so we don't get people you know
converting in race the United States
that was probably an illusion since they
converted at least a Muslim to converted
virtually no one but at least no one who
Christian they did have this strong
feeling that converting someone from
Catholicism or Orthodox Christianity was
almost as converting them from from
heathenism because Protestantism was
just so much better we don't have any
very good comparative histories of
Protestant and Catholic missions it's
rather interesting that the Catholics we
have many many more Souls than the
Protestants do but the Protestants
talkable
endlessly these vast eyes that we have
at Union Theological Seminary in other
places America become and these are
ardent those who after 1830 where we
have the names of individual
missionaries we know a great deal about
their lives they did not expect to come
back they thought they would die in in
the mission in the mission field and
many of them did commitment
as time moves on we also find that it is
a as with the British opium merchants in
Canton it's a good place for gay people
because you know nobody nobody cares
particularly for you know if you were a
really really well it woman say in the
early the end of the 19th early 20th
century you could not be a lawyer you
could not be a doctor you could not be a
businessman but you could be a
missionary and as a missionary you
actually could run a really big
operation and be highly respected but
you would not if you were with your
husband because then he would be the
Reverend dr. so-and-so the the wife of
the Reverend doctor so but see female
missionaries you know their area for a
compliment was unlimited as long as they
left the United States and it's notable
how many really fine missionaries there
were who look superficially at least to
have been lesbian we usually don't have
detailed documentation the one case that
comes to mind as a woman went to India
she'd been there for 20 years
came back gave speeches in Connecticut
about how wonderful it is to be bringing
Christianity to the to the Indians and a
young woman in the audience was so this
is the story was so inspired by her
preaching that she decided she already
trained as a physician would go to India
and become a missionary also and living
as the woman who was giving the sermons
and together they would adopt children
the Barnard student who wrote the senior
thesis that uncovered all this
or aged when I suggested that there
might be a lesbian relationship here so
though I don't never say anything about
that they're adopting children together
no what is it all about only male
children know they adopt sons
anyway these these examples could be
multiplied the 19th century was a period
of intense religiosity in many parts of
the world it's also a period of the
Muslim say I I'm not sure that if we
were looking at all these things under
the category of charisma and a yearning
for charisma whether we could easily
distinguish between religious and
secular charisma Lunken going to history
the Zionist movement for example and
find questions along these lines as to
whether one is religiously inspired to
go back to Eretz Israel or whether one
is doing it as part of a socialist
project or a nationalist enterprise the
boundary between nationalism and
religion becomes a somewhat fuzzy
boundary in numerous cases but not in
the general historiography that we have
so the master narratives that we
cultivate are eager to talk about the
invocation of Italy unification of
Germany and the rise of nationalism
in Russia or higher or other places
where you can see seeds of nationalism
popping up in the second half of 19th
century and you can often with these
early nationalist movements sort of
count the number of participants on you
know when the fingers of both hands and
but that's the way movements tend to
start
but we tend not to tell the story of
religious movements at all and I think
that there was a good reason for that
when the master narratives of modern
history were being constructed wherever
that was because it was assumed that in
the sort of let's say the academic
million it's this sort of construction
done it was assumed that the world was
it seems to me that since we have know
that the modern world of the 21st
century is not univocal II a secular
world that we really need to go back and
revisit the master narratives and say
where does this religiosity come is it
something that we look at case a case
and say okay here we'll talk about the
the mad bowl of Somalia as the British
called they're not there the sufi who
resisted them in somalia do we look at
his movement and then we look at some
other movement and in Indonesia
maybe separately or do we do we do Li
aggregate them and do we aggregate them
qua religious movements or do we
aggregate them qua appeals to to intense
feeling on the part of followers in
which we we throw the nationalism and
the socialism and so forth into the same
hopper if we do that
of course it screws up the history
terribly because of you know we we're no
longer able to distinguish easily
between what is positive and what is not
positive but but if we do it then we get
to the question of why was there such
intensity of feeling in the world in the
19th century now maybe it isn't any
different from the 18th century I think
it was and my suspicion is that it's
related to two changes that are coming
about in an era of economic change and
industrialization changes like
increasing urbanism
that it may be that these movements work
find more resume in urban millou's or
alternatively did me that as people
leave for the city of people out in the
boondocks become more conservative and
return to their roots and of atomistic
and rebellious fashion as with the eight
trigrams rebellion did they have to do
with literacy and that the means of
communicating become better I don't know
but I think that
let's say the spirit of the 19th century
is not simply the modern project
outlined by item and the Scientific
Revolution and the Industrial Revolution
culminating in the in the great surge of
Imperial colonial political occupation
around the world I think that there is a
different dynamic to the 19th century
that needs to be needs to be recovered
that's that's a nice polite historical
terms let's say needs to be invented out
of whole cloth by some clever historian
about probably not me I'm too old for
that now but nevertheless when you read
the history of the chapters that we've
had for the last couple of weeks and
ones we'll have and we a couple weeks to
come just keep in mind is the 19th
century best understood as a series of
sort of autonomous movements in
different places you know you patient of
Italy the rise of full storm sentiment
in Russia you know Taiping rebellion in
China the Meiji Restoration this is this
all simply a series of separate stories
that are being mushed into the same
century or is there something that is
potentially conceivable as a unifying
maybe meta historical version of the
19th century I don't know but
it's been fun to talk about it for the
last hour and 20 minutes so I'll stop
here but when you when you check
out